welcome to this video playing maestro
asked are you always place this this
stuff g3 let me check again who that is
i Lex a Kiwi key VF q AF okay so and
yeah more that's very that's very
exciting okay check let's just let's
just go for that wow yeah that's very
equal ish
right see 495 or something hmm maybe
something I can do probably not young
doubling on the default
yeah I'm thinking I rest a bit of him
yeah he's got to learn something here
that he provoked some provoked some kind
of weakness here i played this a little
bit little bit too yeah I don't know not
paying enough attention maybe but I
don't think it's something serious now
okay that that is related to me can I
don't believe in this so now at night on
e six is kind of wrong let's regroup it
might be 70 60 for something like that I
ok wants to place you for it seems I
have attended 28 also not getting
anywhere I can play knight c6 then very
Jewish again
yeah I'd rather bleed black in this
position and I mean I am like but still
fields again very George I wonder if g5
is a movie actually it is a bit
counterintuitive but intending to take
and the night age 82 g6 something like
that draw a heart no no no no no anybody
is better here it's me and it's quite
five i mean i can i really don't see how
i should ever lose this position so i
can easily continuum it's however as I
said very draw something night somewhere
I don't see it f-for what about f
forceps into something there for the g4
is going to be played if I Tiki for and
then play g5 I am probably not getting
anywhere mmm okay
ok I want to regroup a little bit see if
he takes on b5 I wonder if this if you
would do that I think I can I can always
take on your forehead and shuffle
there's no particular rush here with
every with anything 96th maybe yes
Bishop evade of course and this is when
I have to go back no he actually allows
that so we will have this trade or the
advance that's interesting and now I
have gained the c6 square for the night
which means i can at the right moment
jump jump to deform Knight to c6 and
possibly to deform it's at least a
little gain probably not not anything to
write home about as they save it Knight
to f6 also as a possibility
[ __ ] check you cannot go to e3 here we
does check ok I can just take now there
then take on before I turn there is no
tactic or whatever over to f5 time
wearing apparel and take the snow and
and also h4
yeah that was a slow grind but
ultimately I got them white resigns yeah
well this was I mean I don't really
think that much happened for a very long
time like here I felt that I'm on a
slight pressure maybe on the queenside
but it shouldn't be anything substantial
really what I wat watch out he surprised
me was that can that he had he traded
that and then again he oddity that he
went for that end game we're getting be
five I mean after that i'm completely
safe from losing and if anything my
night is a little bit better here to
maneuver but why it's nothing serious
also h4 i found surprising that he would
put upon on it on a dark square now g5
young but he asking me to still there's
still not much going on f5 yeah i
maneuvered around i was surprised that
yet that he allowed that because this as
i said gives me a little bit of an
additional option putting the knight on
c6 and it's probably still a draw yeah
this is a mistake i think if he just
stay sir nothing happens but now it gets
it gets to be a bit tricky I don't know
what the best continuation is now for
him the engine gives King d3 yeah after
which
this night this is interesting Jack's
cheeks hmm it's it's a funny pollution I
find it remarkable that the engine is
saying that this should be a draw nah
not never I don't believe that in one
bed with three weaknesses on a dark
square maybe I'm may be so difficult to
believe yeah and this is what I think
this is probably losing yeah yeah okay
this is losing but King d3 is a bit a
bit tougher this this this yeah but oh
check now that should win in the long
run but it's far more difficult than in
the game change the game it was easier i
mean i just got the B for ball and you
know this is fairly simple technical
play that even I couldn't screw up
and promotes yeah kind of interesting
endgame surprising that I could win this
but sometimes everything falls into
place thanks for watching